there's no fire inside of you only
darkness it sustains you drains you of
any desire your only joy is in causing
death and even that is fleeting but
killing is the only thing that matters
because you are by nature a murderer
hello and welcome to Hunter hunter 101
the series that breaks down everyone and
everything in the Hunter hunter world
and today we are going to be exploring
the terrifying expressionless assassin
illumise old ik illumise old dick is a
tall slender man aptly aesthetically
characterized by his long jet-black hair
and ever so large similarly black eyes
which seemed to be entirely devoid of
pupils and as much said love to tell you
about enemy's personality to say that he
has one is a bit of a stretch alum E's
crowning feature is instead his almost
complete lack of emotion or more
accurately display of emotion as a
result he is frequently portrayed as one
of the coldest characters in the series
however deep deep and I mean very deep
down there certainly are a degree of
complex thoughts and feelings within
alumi and to really understand this it
initially needs to be said that ellamy
is the firstborn child of silver and
kikyo zoldak the leaders of the world's
most famous family of assassins
therefore as a child Ilham ii was
trained in the industry of murder which
is an art form that illumi excelled at
and to this day performs to a clinical
standard of perfection
however the ruthless degree to which ELA
me and the rest of the soul dicks
carrying out their profession does not
necessarily apply to their familial
relationships as in many ways as all
decks function as a fairly regular
household a primary example of which
here would be ill amis relationship with
his younger brother kilowatt throughout
the entirety of the series Allah meeya
is a clear antagonist to kill WA however
the spawns from a twisted form of love
and overprotectiveness that alumi
harbors towards his younger brother
throughout killer was childhood Allah me
assisted their father in training him
and even inserted a somewhat
mind-controlling needle into his head to
ensure that killer only ever faced an
opponent that he was 100% sure that he
could defeat speaking of her needles
though they appeared to be ill amis
favorite weapon to use in combat and he
possesses at least three different kinds
that when infused with nan can be
utilized in different ways this is
because Allah is a manipulator and is
thus capable of using his aura to
directly control living on non living
beings and enemy makes great use of his
nan affinity by coating needles in his
aura which once coming into contact with
the target will provide Allah me with
direct control of their actions one such
heart who is known as needle people
which involves a lemon piercing the
skull of the living person with one of
his needles and from there
illumi is able to issue the individual
with the command which the target will
then be forced to complete or die in the
process quite notably though should a
needle person complete their mission and
survive the ordeal and they will still
be rendered crippled for the remainder
of their lives although an even greater
method of manipulation is demonstrated
in the corpse control hatsue whereby
illumi can manipulate a deceased
individual by piercing their head with
many many needles ulemas corpse puppets
are than capable of complex actions such
as speaking or driving and for all
intents and purposes they could pass for
an autonomous living person however it
is implied that corpse control were
quite significantly more time and effort
to enact the needle people although
ellamy can also use his abilities a more
subtle less murdery ways the primary
example of which being hypnotic spell
this was the technique that he performed
on killer by inserting an aura clad
needle into his brain with a set of
orders or conditions unlike the other
methods of manipulation in this case the
target does retain full autonomy with
the sole exception of when they violate
ill amis conditions which in this case
of kilowatt was to never engage in
combat with an opponent with which he is
unsure of victory and the consequence
for doing so was an overwhelming feeling
of fear which in some cases was even
able to cause paralysis within kilowatt
and finally LME is also entirely capable
of using his needle pals on himself by
placing them strategically around his
body in order to completely change his
appearance although according to LME
this transformation is exceptionally
painful to enjoy although it would be in
this film that we were first exposed to
the character villain me during the
hunter exam arc Lemmy needed to acquire
his hunter's license for an upcoming
assassination mission however he was
also taking the exam out of concern to
kill WA who had run away from the Zodiac
estate and decided to take the exam for
fun under these conditions alumi assumed
a new face and called himself get Iruka
and for most of the exam he was a fairly
quiet individual who passed each stage
for these in fact during the fourth
phase II Lemmy completed his condition
so quickly that he even had time to dig
a hole and take a nap take a nap inside
the hole that is look don't judge it
until you've tried it but something that
was brought to our attention during this
portion of the story is the fact that
ellamy appears to somehow have formed a
strange bond with Hisako Mara for
whatever reason these two will often be
seen working together
although alumi has acknowledged that he
always believed this relationship would
end with one of them killing the other
in any case ill amis clever ruse would
be revealed in the final stage of the
hunter exam and due to the effects of
hypnotic spell
alumi was able to force a killer to
forfeit a match against him and go on to
obtain his hunter's license he let me
then went on to make sporadic
appearances throughout the series but
arguably his most important role would
be during the 13th
- chairman election Ark in which he was
the primary antagonist during this time
enemy's goal was to kill his younger
sister aleca who harbored a being from
the Dark Continent inside of her this
creature named nanika had seemingly
infinite power expressed through the
medium of wish-granting however they
came at a horrific cost that increased
in direct correlation to the power of
the wish desired fearing the killer
would use the wish to restore his friend
gone illumi began a campaign of
unrivaled sorta enlisting an absurd
amount of needle people as well as
Hisoka to help him however in this case
allah we had a very uncharacteristic
secret goal in mind whereby he was
planning to take control of allah his
abilities showing for the first time in
the series allah mieze deep-seated
emotions of desire and lust for power
although in the end of me does acquiesce
to kill allah is the only one who can
control aleca although that just changed
amis focus to controlling kill OA in
order to control allaka by proxy but
putting that aside for now
allah meas most recent mission in the
series has to do with longtime partner
in crime Hisoka as it seems their
relationship has finally hit his climax
with Hisoka putting out a hit on himself
and actively hiring hilum each try and
kill him and in this effort allah me has
temporarily joined the phantom troupe
and boarded the black whale 1 a vessel
bound for the dark continent some more
fun facts about allah me illumise ren is
said to be one of the most sinister and
terrifying in the entire series and
allegedly can be felt from several
hundred meters away
moving on to some differences now in the
1999 anime series allah me actually
engages in brief combat with gone
following the hunter exam moving to the
2011 anime series so there is a
continuity error in which allah me makes
an appearance in killers flashback
sporting his trademark long black hair
however in another flashback set in the
same time period he is shown to have
short hair hmm and finally a truly
useless fact in the Hunter hunter data
book the official spelling of LME's name
is yel me Sol dick Dodd a book you've
done it again this is why no one reads
you but that pretty much does it for
illumise ol dick if you enjoyed this
video and the content this channel
produce in general then please do
consider donating to the new world of
your patreon because the support of all
of your amazing people is what continues
to make this channel possible and if
patreon isn't quite your style then
please do leave this video a like share
or subscribe because it also helps for
this channel an incredible amount and if
you'd like to join the fun at any time
then please do head over to my discord
server where a wide array of shenanigan
takes place on a daily basis and finally
please do comment with who what or where
you'd like to see featured on the next
danta 101
you